robbing us yet another very embarrassing
question believe it or not even though
tens of thousands of papers have been
written about consciousness in the
literature nobody has a suitable
definition for consciousness what does
it mean to be conscious and how do you
encode it and what is the minimum amount
of consciousness necessary to animate
something else this raises questions for
artificial intelligence because some
people in the field of AI believe that
one day we will be immortal we will live
forever but the question is what will
live forever the atoms that make up our
body they give us consciousness that
give rise to our personality and our
fears and desires that may die but yet
the essence of the neural circuits may
survive now there many ways to do this
so let's break some of them down the
most ambitious has been proposed by
people who believe that one day we will
create a robot body that is perfect
a Superman beautiful elegant
super-powerful body with no brain then
we will start to extract our brain
tissue neuron for neuron and duplicate
it with transistors so for every neuron
we take out of our brain we've replaced
it with a transistor sooner or later
chunks of our brain are removed and
inserted transistor for transistor
inside this robot body
now we're fully conscious during this
process part of our brain computes here
and part of our brain computes over
there connected by wires well after a
few hours large portions of the brain
are gutted and huge chunks of
transistors are added to this robot of
silicon and steel and when it's finally
finished you now have no brain in your
head and here's a robot with a complete
brain and a complete body that's one of
the most ambitious ways to transfer
consciousness from our body to another
body and then the question is is that
really you well there's another way to
do it and that way was explore
in the sixth day with Arnold
Schwarzenegger in that movie the bad
guys get killed but each bad guy was
cloned cloned and somebody was able to
somehow photograph all the memories of
our brain and insert these memories into
the clone now we don't know how to do
that obviously that's way beyond our
technology so don't expect Arnold
Schwarzenegger to come back fully formed
with all his memories as a clone that's
not going to happen anytime soon however
the initial steps are once again being
made at Caltech for example they've been
able to take a mouse brain and look at a
certain part of the brain where memories
are processed memories are processed at
the very center of our brain and they've
been able to duplicate the functions of
that with its chip so again this does
not mean that we can encode memories
with a chip but it does mean that we've
been able to take the information
storage of a mouse brain and have a
silicon chip duplicate those functions
and so what Mouse consciousness created
in the process I don't know I don't know
whether there are mouse's conscious or
not but it does mean that at least in
principle maybe it's possible to
transfer our consciousness and at some
point maybe even become immortal